foreign
[Music]
so you've been studying the quantum
Realm
[Music]
why didn't you ask me about it I tried
Mom
a lot you never wanted to talk about it
Cassie's just been curious and we gave
her some pointers this isn't exactly ant
science is it Henry
you know how dangerous the quantum realm
is that we all do Mom nobody's going to
the quantum realm that's why we made
this
like a satellite for deep space or the
ocean
thank you
we just need a map
and then we can study and explore the
entire Quantum Realm
never even have to go
your daughter built a subatomic Hubble
telescope in a basement
[Music]
gone and
I could have found him
you're an interesting man Scotland
you're an Avenger
you have a daughter but you've lost a
lot of time like me
who are you I'm the man who can give you
more time
Scott you cannot trust him I
was so much he can give us a second
chance
he will bring me what I need for
everything you call a life will end
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
ready PG-13 in theaters February 17th
[Music]